.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Wenn wir etwas zur Beruhigung geben,
wird die Atmung viel schlechter.
Mami. Mami.
Immer mehr Patientinnen
und Patienten, zu wenig Personal.
Kannst du mir da einen Zugang legen?
Ich sehe, dass sich die Situation
in den letzten Jahren
drastisch geändert hat.
Die Notfallstationen in der Schweiz
sind überlastet.
Es tut ihm wahrscheinlich weh,
weil es so geschwollen ist.
Für die Patienten
bleibt häufig zu wenig Zeit.
Die Arbeitsbelastung
ist meistens sehr hoch bei uns.
Achtung.
- Noch mal ein bisschen entspannen.
Was läuft schief auf den
Notfallstationen in der Schweiz?
Das ist etwas, das sich im Schweizer
Gesundheitswesen abzeichnet:
Dass die Sicherheit
infrage gestellt werden darf.
Auch bei Ihnen?
- Auch bei uns hier, ja.
Einfach mitkommen.
Wir - ein Reporterteam
des Schweizer Fernsehens -
begleiten eine Spätschicht
auf dem Kispi-Notfall in St. Gallen.
Wir wollen wissen:
Unter welchen Umständen
wird eigentlich gearbeitet?
Ginja Busch,
26 Jahre alt, Pflegefachfrau.
Seit drei Jahren
arbeitet sie auf der Notfallstation
des Kinderspitals St. Gallen.
Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
Ginja Busch
nimmt uns mit auf die Station.
Es ist Freitagabend, Schichtbeginn.
Hallo, Ginja.
- Hoi.
Ich bin jetzt ready.
Was soll ich machen?
Du kannst entspannt starten
und schauen,
welche Neuerungen
im Infobuch stehen.
Super. Okay, gut. Perfekt.
Freitag ist immer wahnsinnig.
Wieso?
Ich glaube,
weil das Wochenende bevorsteht.
Dann kommt man eher auf den Notfall,
weil man weiss:
"Oh, ich kann morgen keinen Termin
beim Kinderarzt machen."
Kinderärzte
sind wohl auch überlastet
und können am Freitagnachmittag
nicht so schnell
jemanden reinschieben.
Grüezi, Gübeli ist mein Name.
Bereits seit einer halben Stunde im
Dienst ist Oberärztin Cinthia Gübeli.
Sie ist
die Leiterin dieser Notfallschicht.
Du bist Julian? Hoi, wie geht's?
Gut.
-Gut. Tut es weh?
Nein.
- Was ist genau passiert?
Umgefallen.
- Okay. Wie?
Hast du es vergessen? Schon?
Soll dein Papa erklären?
Er war mit Kollegen
nach der Schule auf dem Heimweg.
Dann spielten sie miteinander -
draussen hat es ja Schnee
und ist gefroren -,
fielen um und schon war es passiert.
Waren Sie beim Kinderarzt?
- Ja.
Was hat er gemacht?
Das könne er so nicht.
Das sei zu tief.- Ja. Okay.
Dass Kinderärzte
Eltern an den Notfall verweisen,
werden wir an diesem Abend oft hören.
Genau.
Ja. Super.
Da muss man nähen.
Super machst du das.
Ich habe Angst vor dem Nähen.
- Ja.
Wenn du willst,
kriegst du Zauberluft zum Atmen.
Dann geht es tipptopp.
Zauberluft - das ist Lachgas.
Um die Kinder zu beruhigen.
Das ist nicht so tief.
Ich denke nicht,
dass die Sehnen oder so kaputt sind.
Vom Knochen her
würde ich auch kein Röntgen machen.
Wir machen ein Zaubergel drauf.
Das muss eine Stunde wirken.
Man hört immer wieder,
dass die Leute wegen Nichtigkeiten
auf den Notfall gehen.
Der Notfall sei überlastet.
Wie sehen Sie das?
Das sehe ich auch so.
Darum war mein erster Weg
zum Hausarzt.
Wenn er sagt,
es sei ein Notfall, geht man halt.
Eine Schnittwunde am Knie:
Ist das tatsächlich ein Notfall
oder eher eine Bagatelle?
Das ist ein gewöhnlicher Fall.
Das sehen wir sehr häufig.
Mehrmals pro Tag, würde ich sagen.
Ähm ... Ja, ziemlich ...
... banal, würde ich sagen.
Es ist keine tiefe Wunde.
Das ist auf dem Notfall
schnell genäht.
Warum schickt der Kinderarzt
einen banalen Fall in den Notfall?
Die Antwort auf diese Frage
werden wir später erhalten.
Ginja, Dr. Sutter schickt Timo,
mit Verdacht auf Appendizitis.
Zwei Tage Bauchweh,
Übelkeit, Diarrhö.
Das kommt in so 30, 40 Min.
Soll ich es Nicole nach vorne geben?
- Gerne.
Was passiert?
Wir haben
eine Anmeldung eines Hausarztes:
Verdacht auf Appendizitis,
Blinddarmentzündung, bei einem Kind.
Da rufen sie jeweils kurz an,
damit wir wissen,
was so in der Pipeline ist.
Ginja Busch erzählt uns,
dass sie schon während der Ausbildung
zur Pflegefachfrau gewusst habe:
Sie will einmal
auf dem Notfall arbeiten.
Man muss das schnell Wechselnde, den
Stress und den Druck cool finden.
Alle, die hier arbeiten,
finden das cool, ja.
Jetzt muss ich das anschreiben,
sonst vergesse ich es.
Was ist cool
und wo beginnt die Überlastung?
Das wollen wir
an diesem Abend herausfinden.
Was ist mit Timo?
Gut. Ich nehme Timo.
(Gübeli) Super machst du das.
Cinthia Gübeli
näht nebenan die Wunde von Julian.
Wie gewünscht hat der Bub
zur Entspannung Lachgas gekriegt.
Hast du etwas gespürt?
- Nein.
Super.
- (Mann) Wunderbar machst du das.
Tut es weh?
- Nein.
* Klingeln *
Ist das für mich?
So.
Ich habe gar nichts gespürt.
- Das ist doch schön.
Möchtest du schauen,
wie es aussieht?- Nein.
(Vater) Lieber nicht.
- Okay. Super.
Julian wird das Spital
bald verlassen können.
Super gemacht.
Ich mache noch den Verband.
Oberärztin Gübeli ist seit 15 Jahren
in der Notfallmedizin tätig.
Lange Zeit arbeitete sie in Schweden,
seit drei Jahren
ist sie am Kispi St. Gallen.
Egal wo, auf dem Kindernotfall
sei v.a. eines wichtig:
Immer den Eltern und Familien
gut zuhören.
Wir sehen die Kinder meistens
nur kurz - vielleicht 10-15 Min.
Die Familien und Eltern
kennen die Kinder am besten.
Also einfach zuhören
und auf das Bauchgefühl achten.
Ebenfalls eingeteilt
ist der Leiter der Station:
Ivo Iglowstein.
Er macht einen Zusatzdienst,
um das Personal zu entlasten.
Sag es mir.
Ich bereite den Xylo vor.
Gut. Ja, das ist gut.
Auch auf Ivo Iglowstein
wartet ein Patient,
bei dem genäht werden muss.
Also zu Beginn
brennt es ein bisschen -
wie bei Brennnesseln.
Und am Schluss schläft es so gut,
dass es nicht mehr wehtut.
Mund zu,
Kopf ein bisschen nach hinten.
Ja, super.
Jetzt macht es ganz kurz aua.
Achtung.
Der vierjährige Mirza
hat sich die Lippe aufgerissen.
Entschuldigung.
A sagen. So.
* Klopfen *
Wunderbar. Schon gut.
Auch Patient Mirza
mit seiner Lippenverletzung
wurde vom Hausarzt
ans Spital überwiesen.
Den Fall,
den wir gerade gesehen haben:
Ist das eher ein Bagatellfall?
- Ja.
Also, ein Bagatellfall
für eine Notfallstation.
Aber da kann man
nicht einfach nicht zum Doktor.
Sonst hat man das ein Leben lang.
Aber ich sage, vor 20 Jahren wurde
das in jeder Hausarztpraxis gemacht.
Haus- und Kinderarztpraxen seien
für diese sog. kleine Traumatologie
nicht mehr ausgerüstet,
sagt Iglowstein.
Und das habe einen Grund.
Das ist von der Politik gewollt
und vom Sparen. Man will ja sparen.
Hausärzte haben kein Röntgen mehr,
Kinderärzte sowieso nicht.
Dann kommt alles, was Trauma ist,
wo Röntgen nur infrage kommt,
automatisch ins Spital.
Das sei einer der Gründe,
warum
viel mehr Patienten und Patientinnen
bei ihnen auf dem Notfall landeten,
sagt Iglowstein.
Dass die meisten unnötig kämen,
will er nicht bestätigen.
Ich nehme Timo, oder? Freunde?
Es ist später Nachmittag.
Noch sei die Anzahl der Patienten
überschaubar, sagt uns Ginja Busch.
Bist du Timo?
Hoi, mein Name ist Busch.
Ich bin Pflegefachfrau.
Wir gehen ins Zimmer und schauen,
was passiert. Ja? Super.
Die Mappe nehme ich.
Diesen Beutel nimmst du.
Falls es kommt ... Gell? Super.
Patient Timo ist 13 Jahre alt
und kommt aus Appenzell Innerrhoden
auf den Kispi-Notfall St. Gallen.
Haben Sie ihm
schon ein Schmerzmittel gegeben?
Ja, heute Morgen, 8.45 Uhr, Algifor.
Wie hast du es jetzt
mit den Schmerzen, Timo?
Es tut stark weh, aber ...
So fest, dass ich
noch mal etwas bringen soll
oder hältst du es aus?
- Ich halte es aus.
Okay, schauen wir
noch einmal auf den Bauch.
Jetzt darfst du mir zeigen,
wo es wehtut.
Ja, da.
- Da? Nicht da, sondern da?- Ja.
Jetzt machen wir
eine kleine Bauchmassage.
Geht es? Gut. Das war schon alles.
Also,
ich sage den Ärzten Bescheid.
Sie kommen dann zu Ihnen.
Ist das gut? Super. - Danke.
So.
Ist es bequem?
Sollen wir die Beine hochlagern?
Nein, ist gut.
- Ein warmer Beutel auf den Bauch?
- Gut, super. Dann bis später.
Pflegefachfrau Busch
wird ihre Einschätzung
nun dem Ärzteteam rapportieren.
Das Kind
ist in einem stabilen Zustand.
Es hat sicher Zeichen
für eine Blinddarmentzündung,
mit diesen Unterbauchschmerzen.
Ich denke aber nicht, dass es
in eine instabile Situation rutscht.
Genau.
Sie wird recht behalten:
Timo hat keine Blinddarmentzündung.
Weil Platz und Personal
knapp sind auf der Notfallstation,
werden alle Fälle triagiert.
D.h.: Dringendes hat Priorität.
Das Jonglieren mit Zeit
und Ressourcen -
ein ständiges Thema hier.
(Frau) Wie lange dauert das?
- (Iglowstein) Bis Sie gehen können?
Wenn nicht dauernd
andere, stark kranke Kinder kommen,
vielleicht eine Stunde.
- Okay.
Ist das okay?
- Ja. Danke.- Gut. Bis später.
Danke.
Die Patientenzahlen
auf dem Kispi-Notfall in St. Gallen
haben sich in den letzten zehn Jahren
verdoppelt.
Das Einzugsgebiet des Spitals
ist gross.
Babys und Kinder bis 16 Jahre
aus den Kantonen Thurgau,
St. Gallen und den beiden Appenzell
kommen hierher.
Die Patientenzunahme
der letzten Jahre hat Kostenfolgen:
Die Behandlung auf dem Notfall
kostet im Schnitt doppelt so viel
wie beim Haus- oder Kinderarzt.
(Busch)
Ajla, du darfst dich hier hinsetzen.
Okay.
- Sie hat Husten und Halsweh?
Pflegefachfrau Ginja Busch
hat eine neue Patientin:
die dreijährige Ajla aus Niederuzwil.
Okay,
schauen wir mal den Ausschlag an.
Seit wann hat sie den?
(Mutter) Ich war arbeiten, kam
nach Hause und da fiel es mir auf.
Die Mutter des Mädchens erzählt uns,
warum sie
direkt auf den Notfall gekommen ist,
anstatt
zuerst zum Kinderarzt zu gehen.
Er ist voll überlastet.
Man kriegt kaum Termine.
Ich habe drei Kinder und für keines
kriege ich einen Termin.
Sie ist die Älteste.
Ich bin froh, dass er
überhaupt alle aufgenommen hat.
Er hat sie nur aufgenommen,
weil es Neugeborene waren.
Sonst hätte er sie nicht genommen.
Ein absoluter Engpass.
Gut. Tut dir noch etwas weh?
Ich habe Halsweh.
- Starkes Halsweh?
Oder ein bisschen stark?
- Ein bisschen stark.
Ein bisschen stark.
Hältst du es aus?
Sie dürfen einen Moment warten.
Wenn in der Zwischenzeit was ist,
dürfen Sie sich hier melden.
Die Ärzte kommen dann. Ist das gut?
Super. Bis später. - Danke.
Es wird sich herausstellen,
dass das Mädchen Ajla Scharlach hat.
Eine Diagnose, die nicht auf dem
Notfall hätte gemacht werden müssen.
Doch solche Fälle von Eltern, deren
einzige Anlaufstelle der Notfall sei,
hätten sich gehäuft,
sagt uns Ivo Iglowstein.
Die Grundversorgung in der Schweiz
ist nicht mehr in allen Regionen
und für alle Alterskategorien
wirklich gut tragfähig.
Grundversorgung heisst Hausärzte?
Haus- und Kinderärzte in der Praxis.
Und was seit Mai 2021 bis jetzt
dazugekommen ist:
Die Grundversorger
sind auch am Limit.
Wenn sie nicht mehr können,
wird auf den Notfall verwiesen.
Und das kommt kumuliert bei uns an.
Die hohen Notfallzahlen
lassen sich also erklären
mit weniger Haus- und Kinderärzten,
überlasteten Kinderärzten
und Praxen,
die nicht mehr ausgerüstet sind,
um die sog. kleine Traumatologie
zu übernehmen.
Was nirgends Platz findet,
landet auf dem Notfall.
Doch hier trifft mehr Arbeit
auf zu wenig Personal.
Die denkbar schlechteste Kombination.
- Das ist ein Fall für uns.
Ich muss mich kurz einlesen.
Eine Atemwegproblematik.
Da müssen wir immer zackig sein.
Atemprobleme.
Es steht "Verdacht auf Pneumonie",
also Lungenentzündung.
Das ist Triage 2.
Das ist ziemlich dringlich.
(Frau) Kann ich mitkommen?
Ich habe den Anruf angenommen.
Es ist der erste dringliche Fall für
Pflegefachfrau Busch an diesem Abend.
Mit dabei:
Assistenzärztin Jeannine Heetmeyer.
Ich bin Busch, Pflegefachfrau.
Sie dürfen mitkommen.
Und sie ist Assistenzärztin.
Ganz viele Leute für Ilona.
Sie können mir die Mappe geben.
- Seit wann hat sie Fieber?
Sie dürfen Ilona
auf die Liege legen.
Und gerne das T-Shirt
und alles ausziehen,
damit man den Brustkorb gut sieht.
Ist das gut?
Hi. Hi. Ich weiss, das ist doof.
Alles ist doof hier, oder?
Zum ersten Mal haben wir den
Eindruck, Ginja Busch sei angespannt.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Ja.
Hopp.
Ja, super.
- Super, Ilona. Bravo.
Wollen Sie ihr ein Büchlein geben,
dass sie sich ansehen kann?
Vielleicht lenkt es sie etwas ab.
Das lenkt noch mehr ab. Super.
- Ich zeige ihr YouTube.
Schau.
Sie ist zentralisiert.
Tachykard bei 130.
Die Pflegefachfrau will prüfen,
ob das Mädchen
genügend Sauerstoff kriegt.
Du musst so fest weinen ...
Ja, du bist so tapfer.
Du bist so, so tapfer.
Man ist jetzt sicher gestresst,
weil man vorwärtsmachen will.
Wir kriegen die Sauerstoffsättigung
gerade nicht hin.
Das ist interessant, um zu wissen,
ob sie Sauerstofftherapie braucht.
Das braucht sie. Jetzt haben wir es.
Ich lege ihr jetzt
die Maske ans Gesicht.
Ja, sie macht das supergut.
Kennt sie das?
Ilona sei ein frühgeborenes Kind
gewesen, erzählen uns die Eltern.
Darum
sei sie die Sauerstoffmaske gewohnt.
Sie hat auch so eine blasse Trübung.
(Heetmeyer) Wann hatte sie
das letzte Mal was gegen das Fieber?
Gestern.
- Gestern? Heute gar nichts?
Nein.
(Busch)
Kennen Sie ihr Gewicht ungefähr?
(Heetmeyer) Ich glaube, 8,5 kg.
- Ja.
(Busch) Nimmt sie Algifor
oder lieber Zäpfchen? - Ja.
Algifor? Dann bringe ich das.
Okay? Gut, super.
Was war die Frage?
Wie trifft man unter diesem Druck
die richtigen Entscheidungen?
Wir werden sehr gut geschult.
Das sind alles Situationen,
auf die wir geschult werden.
Und ich denke, Fachwissen oder
Schulungen geben auch Sicherheit.
Also,
ich hole schnell das Medikament.
Ilona wird es leider im Verlaufe
des Abends immer schlechter gehen.
Jan?
Sie dürfen gerne mitkommen.
- Ah, super.
Es ist mittlerweile kurz nach 19 Uhr
und die Anzahl Patienten
hat zugenommen.
Das sei üblich,
sagt uns Oberärztin Gübeli.
Gübeli ist mein Name,
Oberärztin auf der Notfallstation.
Darf ich die Unterlagen haben?
- Entschuldigung.
Das kannst du mir geben.
- So. Wie geht's?
Gut.
- Was hast du gemacht?
Wie ist das passiert?
Ich bin
in eine Küchenplatte gerannt.
Warst du so schnell unterwegs?
Mhm.
- Etwas zu schnell gerannt.
Aber sonst geht es dir gut?
Hast du Kopfweh?
Am Anfang schon.
- Aber jetzt nicht mehr.
Kein Erbrechen?
- Nein, gar nicht.
Keine Wesensveränderungen?
- Nein, gar nichts.
Ich gab ihm Arnikakügelchen.
Mehr hatte er nicht.
- Ja. Okay.
Darf ich schauen?
- Mhm.
Möchtest du das Pflaster
selber wegnehmen?
Ist es gut oder soll ich es machen?
Nein. Ich glaube, es ist weg.
- Ja ... So.
Oder?
- (Mutter) Es klebt noch fest.
Aber sie hilft dir.
(Gübeli) Super machst du das.
Oh ja, das muss man nähen.
Du kriegst ein Zaubergel von uns.
Das muss eine Stunde wirken.
Sie dürfen noch mal im Gang warten.
Dann hole ich eine Pflegerin,
die das Gel draufmacht.
Super.
Auch die Verletzung von Jan
ist ein einfacher Fall.
Die Kinderärztin
verwies die Mutter ans Notfallspital.
Wir wollen von der Oberärztin wissen,
wie sehr sie bei der Arbeit
unter Druck steht.
Das ist je nach Dienst
natürlich unterschiedlich.
Aber die Arbeitsbelastung
ist meistens sehr hoch bei uns.
Wir haben ja auch Personalmangel:
zu wenig Pflege, zu wenig Ärzte -
das ist überall so in der Schweiz.
Auf dem Kispi-Notfall in St. Gallen
sind derzeit
nicht alle Stellen besetzt.
Im April
sollte das Team wieder komplett sein.
Mittlerweile ist es 19.30 Uhr und
sämtliche Notfallbetten sind besetzt.
Wollt ihr Nackenschmerzen
in die 9 nehmen?- Mhm.
Wir haben Kapazität.
- Dann die Rettung in die 1?
Ja.
- Super, so machen wir es.
Wann kommt sie?
- In 2-3 Min.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Einfach mitkommen.
Wir sind zurück bei Ilona,
dem Mädchen mit den Atemproblemen.
Aha.
Sie hat relativ hohes Fieber, was
auch das Atmen beeinflussen kann.
Wir geben ihr Algifor
und inhalieren mit Ventolin.
Kennen Sie das?
-Was ist das?
Ein Medikament.
Die Ärztin hat gehört,
dass die Bronchien ziemlich zu sind.
Atmen und Husten ist streng für sie,
wie Sie ja schon bemerkt haben.
Ventolin
macht die Bronchien wieder auf.
Zuerst das Algifor.
Möchten Sie das geben?
Das soll sie machen.
(Mutter) Ja, ja.
Nicht alles wegmachen. Ja, ist gut.
- Das magst du nicht.
Gut.
Wow!
- Ja, jetzt ist gut.
Super.
Beim Inhalieren ist wichtig,
dass sie die Maske
während der ganzen Inhalation
auf dem Gesicht behält.
Es dauert ungefähr 2-3 Min.,
bis ich fertig bin.
Am besten
nehmen Sie sie so auf den Schoss.
Das zweijährige Mädchen
wird an diesem Abend
nicht nach Hause gehen können.
Ja, wir denken ... Ja, ist gut.
* Ilona wimmert. *
(Busch) Super. Sehr gut.
Ihr Zustand wird sich verschlechtern.
Wir inhalieren jetzt alle 20 Min.
Insgesamt drei Mal.
Die Eltern werden uns später bitten,
nicht mehr zu filmen.
Du darfst den Rest sagen.
Röntgen ist in 10 Min.
Dann können Sie hochgehen.
Dann schauen wir uns die Lunge an.
Pflegefachfrau und Assistenzärztin
arbeiten Hand in Hand.
Hierarchiedenken gebe es auf
dem Notfall nicht, sagen die beiden.
Uns wird hier klar,
wie hoch der Druck
und wie anspruchsvoll die Arbeit ist.
Wie lange bleibt man in der Regel
auf einer solchen Station?
Lange, aber nicht 100 %.
Und nicht 90 %.
Ich denke,
wenn man das Pensum reduzieren kann,
ist es etwas anderes.
Wenn man so 50-60 % arbeiten kann.
Bei 90 %
ist man eine begrenzte Zeit hier.
Aber die nächsten drei Jahre
bin ich sicher mal hier.
100 % zu arbeiten geht nicht?
- Nicht auf dem Notfall.
Für mich war das nicht möglich.
Auch auf anderen Stationen ...
Ich kenne fast niemanden ...
Alle Freunde aus der Pflege
arbeiten 90 %.
Es ist schwierig, das bei 100 %
langfristig auszuhalten.
Ah.
Ich komme spätestens
um fünf vor halb noch mal.
Ich muss kurz bei
den anderen Patienten vorbeischauen.
Wenn sich etwas ändert,
dürfen Sie sich hier melden.
Sie dürfen sie auch zu sich nehmen,
wenn sie sich so beruhigt.
Gut? Super. Sonst einfach klingeln.
Okay, gut. Bis später.
Beim Röntgen wird sich herausstellen,
dass Ilona eine Lungenentzündung hat.
Anna?
Was ist jetzt?
Jetzt ist Notfall.
Das Problem ist, dass
das Kind aktuell nicht gut atmet.
Ich möchte bei ihr sein, habe aber
noch nicht alles dokumentiert.
Nur das Gröbste.
Und ich möchte sie beobachten.
Allenfalls braucht sie mehr
bei der Sauerstofftherapie.
Es war
jetzt auch viel für die Eltern.
Und ich habe einen anderen Patienten
vom anderen Dienst übernommen.
Er braucht einen Zugang mit Labor,
um dann ein CT zu machen.
Ich habe gemerkt, dass ich den
besser an jemand anderen abgebe.
Ich habe gerade
keine Kapazität für beide.
Und draussen ist noch ein Kind,
das sich jemand anschauen muss.
Das macht jetzt Manuel. Hoi, Giulia.
- Hallo.
Stationsleiter Ivo Iglowstein
hat die Unterlippe
des vierjährigen Mirza genäht.
Gut, den Mund noch mal
schnell öffnen. A machen.
Mund auf. A.
- Gut.
Dort hat es noch ein bisschen.
Gut.
Entschuldigung.
Noch die Zähne schauen.
Noch mal A sagen.
(Mutter) Ist ...
(Anna)
Alles gut. Das machen wir immer.
Jetzt sind wir fertig.
- Super.
Danke schön.
- Bravo.
Mirza und seine Mutter
sind aus dem Spital entlassen.
Vom Stationsleiter wollen wir wissen,
ob in dieser Drucksituation
die Sicherheit auf dem Notfall
jederzeit gewährleistet ist.
Wir haben immer wieder Phasen,
in denen wir sagen,
dass es so schwierig ist,
einen Notfall weiter zu betreiben.
Da ist die Sicherheit
nicht mehr rund um die Uhr
für alle Patienten gegeben.
In dem Sinne,
dass ich jederzeit weiss,
wie es welchem Patienten geht.
Wir haben zum Glück gute Redundanz,
mit vielen Leuten,
die beim gleichen Patienten
involviert sind.
Dass es nicht so weit kommt,
liegt daran,
dass die Mitarbeiter
einfach alles und noch mehr geben.
Es ist kurz nach 20 Uhr.
Pflegefachfrau Busch
nimmt uns mit in die Personalküche.
Die Zeit in der Küche ist selten,
darum geniessen wir es umso mehr,
wenn wir zusammensitzen
und 10 Min. Pause machen können.
Denkst du, wir schaffen 10 Min.?
- Schaffen wir 10 Min.?
Du bist optimistisch.
- Immer. Ihr kennt mich ja.
Manchmal
isst man einfach etappenweise.
Man fängt mal an ...
- ... wärmt es dreimal ...
Man fragt sich immer,
ob man etwas Warmes mitnehmen soll.
Unter Umständen
isst man es einfach kalt.
Oder wärmt es dreimal.
Wir wollen vom Team wissen,
wie sie abschalten können
vom Stress der Arbeit.
Ich brauche v.a.
die räumliche Distanz.
Es ist mir wichtig,
weit genug vom Notfall weg zu sein.
V.a. Ablenkung,
um auf andere Gedanken zu kommen.
Man lernt megagut, damit umzugehen.
Z.T. sind wir privat befreundet.
Ich bin mit Ginja befreundet.
Wir haben ein megacooles Team.
Ich könnte mich jedem anvertrauen -
egal, ob beruflich oder privat.
Weil wir ein so eingeschweisstes
und cooles Team haben,
hat das die Situation
in den letzten Monaten und Jahren
auch erträglicher gemacht.
Heute hat es für 10 Min. Pause
gereicht.
Das schaffen sie etwa an
jedem dritten Tag, erzählen sie uns.
Nebenan, bei Oberärztin Gübeli,
sieht es ein bisschen anders aus.
Keine Zeit, um Pause zu machen?
Ja, es geht.
Ich habe schon gegessen.
Ja.
Ich muss den Überblick behalten.
Es sind ein paar Kinder da.
Ich muss schauen,
dass es vorwärtsgeht.
Ja.
Schau mal, jetzt kommt da ...
Pflegefachfrau Busch
hat bereits einen nächsten Fall:
die einjährige Valentina.
Super machst du das.
Super.
Und wer ist das da? Der Hund?
Valentina ist vom Bett gefallen.
Sehr gut. Okay, gut.
Von der Überwachung her
sieht alles tipptopp aus.
Die Ärztin
ist auch schon auf dem Weg. - Danke.
Ist das gut? Gut.
Bis nachher, Valentina.
Zur Sicherheit wird das Mädchen
die Nacht im Spital verbringen.
Ich glaube, nichts, aber ...
Letzte Handgriffe von Ärztin Gübeli
und Pflegefachfrau Anna Klee
beim fünfjährigen Luan.
Grüezi.
Kommt ihr mit rein?
Luan, wird das Bein heiss?
Ist es warm unter dem Gips?
Nein, es ist warm.
- Ist es warm? Ja?
Ja.
- Ja? Gut. Ganz still ...
Luan hat sich beim Trampolinspringen
die Bänder verletzt.
Das ist nicht so schlimm, oder?
Du hast es super gemacht.
Zur Stabilisierung
kriegt er einen Gips.
Jetzt können wir
wegen Gehstöcken schauen.
Ja, hier ist Ginja.
Die Schicht
sei heute normal gewesen,
nicht besonders anstrengend,
sagt uns das Notfallteam.
Aber normal
heisst eben mittlerweile: zu viel.
Tschau.
Pflegefachfrau Busch sagt,
sie bräuchte Entlastung.
Die Schichten
müssten anders entlöhnt werden.
Wir bräuchten mehr Freizeit.
Weil einfach ...
Das ist nicht zu unterschätzen.
24/7 ansprechbar zu sein im Monat
und so arbeiten zu können.
Es wäre schön, wenn man
mehr Erholungszeit kriegen würde,
nicht unbedingt mehr Lohn.
Die Arbeit
auf mehr Personal verteilen
und so die Einzelnen entlasten -
das wäre eine Lösung.
Doch Stationsleiter Ivo Iglowstein
sagt uns,
mehr Personal lasse sich
derzeit gar nicht rekrutieren.
Geht es nicht mehr so weiter?
- Ich glaube nicht.
Mindestens das,
was wir beobachten ...
Die Kosten gehen rauf,
Gesundheitsökonomen und Politiker
sagen,
wir müssen sparen, sparen ...
Und die Leute an der Front
werden verheizt.
Sie sehen es:
Es ist ein Riesendruck,
den die Leute an der Front haben.
Es ist kurz vor 22 Uhr.
Oberärztin Gübeli
hat bei Luan fertig gegipst.
So.
Warum ist es da nass?
- Vom Wasser des Gipses.
Viel Verantwortung
und immer mehr Druck -
der Alltag von Cinthia Gübeli.
Dann machen wir ein Röntgen.
Ist das gut für Sie?- Super.
Ich möchte nicht mehr kommen.
Ich komme allein.
- Gute Besserung.
Sag Danke für den Gips.
- Danke für den Gips.
Danke dir fürs Mitmachen.
Trotz allem Stress:
Noch immer sei es ihr Traumberuf.
Es hat mich immer interessiert,
wie der Mensch funktioniert,
mit der Biologie ...
Wieso kann man so gut hören?
Wie laufen
die Prozesse im Körper ab?
Aber auch mit Menschen zu arbeiten,
finde ich spannend.
(Anna) Gute Besserung.
- Sag Tschüss. Danke.
Tschüss. Gute Besserung.
* Lachen *
Tschüss.
- Danke.
Nach 3 Std.
kann Luan mit seinem Gips nach Hause.
In fünf Wochen
kommt er zum Röntgen wieder.
Ich ziehe mich um. Tschau zusammen.
- Tschüss.
Auf der Station ist Schichtwechsel.
Die meisten Fälle an diesem Abend
waren nicht dringlich.
Das bedeutet keine Fälle
für eine Notfallstation.
Doch egal, wie gross der Druck ist:
Abgewiesen wird hier niemand.
Eine Notfallstation schliesst nie.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023